hi guys dr. Barrick here in this video I
want to answer this question what is
insulin resistance really okay what is
it it's basically the body's defense
mechanism against excess sugar okay
that's what it is
insulin keeps your blood sugars from
going too high okay so insulin prevents
the blood sugars from rising above 100
milligrams per deciliter now what does
that mean let me show you in this next
part okay so this represents the amount
of blood that's in your body these are
filled with blood okay a gallon and a
half of blood okay the one hundred
million milligrams per deciliter is one
teaspoon of sugar per gallon and a half
of blood so if we put that in there we
put this in there we dilute it that
would be normal blood sugar okay so it's
not very much but what does an average
person consume
[Music]
31 teaspoons
okay that's a hundred and forty pounds
of sugar every single year now do you
see the problem okay we're back so now
you know you don't really need much
sugar in your body okay now why does
your body work so hard to keep your
blood Sugar's below 100 that's the
question because sugar is toxic too much
sugar is toxic to the body even at 1/2
of a teaspoon more than you need
chronically taking over a period of time
can create damage just a half a teaspoon
more than you need
and what kind of damage that's
neuropathies that's like damage to your
nerves and your feet in your hands like
in a diabetic blind the optic nerve
creating damage in the eye heart disease
stroke diabetes inflammation memory loss
Alzheimer's sugar feeds cancer visceral
fat that's the fat around the gut okay
so it can create some serious damage
okay you get three types of fuel sources
you have carbohydrates proteins and fats
right
carbohydrates are glucose or sugar so
here's the truth glucose is not the
preferred fuel of the body
like people think fat is the type of
fuel that your body does a lot better on
and the reason why people will say that
glucose is the preferred fuel is because
it's used first it's used at first if
given the choice between fat and sugar
to always go after the sugar first but
the reason why it goes after the sugar
first is because that sugar creates the
most damage so when you eat sugar it
puts the body in emergency situation
where it has to dispose of it first
that's why it doesn't mean it's the
preferred fuel it means that it it's the
most dangerous that needs to be gotten
rid of disposed of in the body so the
body will stick it into the cells it'll
stick it into storage is fat that type
of thing and think about it you have
about 40,000 calories of fat and only
2,000 calories of storage sugar in your
body so our bodies are meant to have
this huge fat reserve or some fat a lot
more fat because it runs on that more
long-term than this quick sugar thing
where you can deplete and probably a
half an hour so insulin is in reality a
detoxifier hormone it is meant to
detoxify excess sugar and sugar is toxic
okay the hidden sugar to the breads the
pasta the cereal crackers I mean how
many people are pre-diabetic now how
many people are going into diabetes how
many people have insulin resistance so
many people so when you burn fat you
actually you can run your body on
something called ketone so ketones are
the byproduct of fat burning and our
bodies can run on ketones very
efficiently okay now can you run a
hundred percent of your body on ketones
no you can run 85% of your fuel on
ketones
15 percent of your fuel needs to be
glucose but here's the catch 22 your
body can make glucose from your own fat
or the fat in the diet or the protein in
the diet it doesn't need external
glucose you don't need to consume
carbohydrates
okay so the 15 percent of the body that
basically runs on glucose that can't run
on ketones would be parts of certain
parts of the brain the outside of the
kidney the lens of the eye the red blood
cell and sperm but again those that
could be converted from fat and sugar
it's called gluconeogenesis in the liver
so fat is a much cleaner fuel it runs on
less oxygen it's less stressful and it
gives off much less waste than sugar
okay so to recap what is insulin
resistance this is a protective
mechanism that your body has created to
prevent the toxic sugar from in bay
the body I hope that helped hey guys I
just want to take a second and thank you
for your recent uploads a lot of you are
uploading your success stories and they
are mind-blowing check out the one from
Jeff before-and-after I mean that's
incredible then we have morose Lowell
and Quinn and a shot and Halina check
out George and Debby John Lee and I mean
this is just a few of the many I mean
it's amazing so I am just blown away so
if you haven't filled out your success
story and uploading it before and after
I want to see it I put a link down below
it's not only mind-blowing to me but it
inspires other people because it gives
them hope that they can be helped as
well so click the link below and share
your success story with me I want to
check it out